last night here at 11 o'clock our 8 news
now investigators showed you how a new
flight pattern out of Reed airport is
actually angering some of the Narrows
the neighbors just below that it is new
at six eight news now investigator David
charns asking Aviation experts if
anything can be done and David what did
he say well he says he's not surprised
to hear there are issues because he's
seen them before we asked if the FAA
needs to look again at how it came to
the conclusion that flying planes over
this part of town wouldn't really change
anything on the ground
shouldn't the FAA be listening to the
people down below yes and there should
be answers there should be actions when
deemed necessary Aviation consultant and
former air traffic controller Kevin
Carpe says the FAA should clarify just
why it's sending planes over this
southwest Valley neighborhood as the 8
news now investigators reported Monday
the faa's Las Vegas Metroplex project is
sending some general aviation aircraft
off runway 19. some commercial flights
also take the route in certain weather
but immediately after takeoff those
planes make a hard right turn right over
the Western Trails neighborhood in this
case the environmental uh review would
have to take place for any
implementation of a procedure that's
where the basic information of what
you're asking would come from Carpe says
the FAA should have reviewed the
departure procedure as part of its
overall environmental review the FAA
says planes have always departed from
Runway 19 but we found a noise study on
the turn didn't account for a change in
type of planes so if you're changing the
mix of make and models of planes you're
not reflecting that in your sound study
wouldn't your sound study need to be
reviewed it might be very very possibly
now two years since Metroplex went into
effect Carpe says the FAA should listen
and work on a potential solution the fa
has been challenged in a lot of
different Avenues across the country
with different metroplexes I have seen
some changed I've seen some amended
now we showed you last night how an FAA
representative says the agency doesn't
have a policy of meeting with individual
neighbors we have asked the FAA for
specific information about that
departure and that right hand turn
spokesperson says they're working on
that request I'm David charns eight news
now David thank you we have also asked
our Congressional Delegation in
Washington for a response and we'll let
you know when we do hear back